tonight white house correspondent peter
ducey tells us the president has been
doing his best to try to avoid some
sticky subjects
the president went for a bike ride
[Music]
went to church
and went to new york without mentioning
failures in afghanistan a booster
program or the border instead staffers
are rolling out new covenant team
policies beginning in early november
foreign nationals
flying to the united states will be
required to be fully vaccinated there's
a big loophole though if somebody walks
into the country right across the river
does somebody ask them to see their
vaccination card
well let me explain to you again if they
have symptoms they are the intention is
for them to be quarantined that is our
process they're not intending to stay
here for a lengthy period of time i
don't think it's the same thing vice
president harris has supposedly been
strategizing for months isn't she
supposed to be addressing the root
causes of migration
absolutely and she has been addressing
the root causes of migration then
there's china fractured ties with
beijing are such a threat the u.n
secretary general tells the ap we need
to avoid at all cost a cold war that
would be different from the past one and
probably more dangerous and more
difficult to manage the white house is
responding he will make absolutely clear
that he is not looking to
pursue a future a new cold war with any
country in the world quite a change
since february diplomacy is back at the
center of our foreign policy the focus
of foreign policy lately the afghan
withdrawal which included a terror
attack that killed americans and a u.s
drone strike that killed civilians this
whole execution has been nothing but a
catastrophe the pentagon is
investigating why was the decision taken
as we've now learned there was another
surveillance drone showing that there
were kids or individuals on the ground i
think you can understand now that we're
going to review this investigation no
plans to change course though you guys
didn't kill people who went after our
troops he killed 10 civilians including
seven children so does the president
still think he's over the horizon
strikes can work
absolutely
refugees in afghanistan with visas are
having a hard time getting out refugees
at the southern border with no visas are
having no trouble getting in but before
these issues vetting refugees are
resolved the administration is
announcing tonight they are going to
double the number allowed into the u.s
each year from 62 500 to 125 000. brett
you know peter was all about follow the
science and then the president had that
speech about the booster program for
vaccines that actually was supposed to
start today yes and
given his remarks a couple weeks ago we
could have circled today on the calendar
and planned on an event where the
president goes out to a booster shot
clinic or maybe even gets the booster
shot himself but that did not happen
today because after the president's
announcement that the boosters were
going to start today 16 out of 18 fda
advisors said the science is not there i
asked jen saki about this earlier this
afternoon and she basically said don't
forget the president said that this is
something that was always going to be
contingent on the fda and on the cdc she
also pointed us to comments from dr
fauci and dr collins over the weekend
that it's an ongoing process right okay
a process we'll follow peter ducey live
on the north lawn peter thanks hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else